that question comes from Chris in Utah
what do you do and how do you hold on to
hope when Murphy keeps coming around to
visit when real emergencies like medical
problems and exploding transmissions
keep wiping out your emergency fund for
the tenth time and sending you further
into debt I've restarted baby step one
so many times I'm losing hope that I can
get out of debt you're in drama mode
Chris you have not restarted the
emergency fund ten times you've
restarted it three or four times but
you're still at a point that you're
losing hope and that's causing your
drama in your exaggeration what happens
with the thing called momentum momentum
when somebody has momentum it's a weird
thing you ever had momentum in an area
in your life like if you play sports
where you're playing a particular that
night that day in that game everything
you did worked like you were in the zone
yet momentum there have been in a
section time with your marriage there
was a time a particular season of your
marriage when you had momentum I mean
things were awesome yeah up seasons when
it's not but I mean you have the season
when it's awesome season in your career
where everything you touch turns to gold
you're in a zone that's when you got
momentum when you have momentum you are
not as good as you look
because you look so good when you don't
have momentum it's the opposite
everything you touch turns to poop your
life looks like a country song you can't
do nothing right everything you say
makes her mad everything you do with the
career makes the boss man everything you
touch them you lose money on it
everything that can break them in your
life looks like a country song you know
and when you don't have momentum Chris
which is right where you are you're
better than you look
things are better than they feel your
feelings will lie to you in both of
these cases they tell you you're better
than you are when you got momentum and
they tell you you're not worth dirt when
you don't have momentum
I remember being down and we're filing
bankruptcy and lights are cut off at the
house and they're coming to cut the
water off and like the dadgum air
conditioner went out I got sweaty babies
and a sweaty mad wife everything's awful
two years before I was a millionaire and
then I said bankrupt him broke now had
my brain completely quit working no the
same brain I had two years before had
the same physical capacities I had two
years before I had the same everything
except the circumstances around me did
not indicate anything except that I was
completely stupid
now I'd done some stupid stuff that put
us there for sure but you know it's
weird it's like what if I said open this
envelope the envelope says you just won
a million dollars
oh my gosh and then you turn it over and
go that's a lie
see how your feelings lie to you your
circumstances cannot dictate whether or
not you are going to win and that's
where hope comes from as part of our
hope that comes from it's a type of
faith and you spiritually have faith
faith in God and God loves me and he's
gonna walk with me through these hard
times and sometimes I can just have
faith to go you know I am smarter than
all this poop around me looks and that's
where you are right now Chris you keep
doing smart things over and over and
over again even though the particular
circumstances you're sitting in don't
say that everything's okay and you'll
walk through this it felt like when I
did not have an emergency fund that all
I had was emergencies
and then when I got a little emergency
fund I noticed I had smaller I had fewer
emergencies when I got a large fully
funded emergency fund of three to six
months of expenses I have never had an
emergency since hardly almost none it's
almost as if I quit having emergencies
when I got a little margin when I got a
little distance between me and that run
of garbage so I know you're scared but
you're better than you look Chris you're
better than you look you're better than
you think you are you're in better shape
and doing smarter things and moving in
the right direction don't stop doing
that don't lose hope proverbs says Hope
deferred makes the heart sick but when
desire comes oh and desire comes that is
the Tree of Life so I got you I
understand been there done that I've
been scared didn't think I was gonna get
out ever didn't think I'd ever get back
up on top again but you will keep doing
smart things even though Murphy seems to
be setting up residence in your house
and eventually you'll look up one day
Murphy moved out and you didn't even
know he left Wow look at that
and anything happened in awhile you
won't even notice it it'll be so subtle
and so incremental you will begin to win
death by a thousand cuts you won't win
in one fell swoop there won't be one
moment where you you get struck by
lightning and win the lotto that's not
how people win people win by a little
bit a little bit a little bit a little
bit a little bit a little bit a little
bit a little bit if you keep taking
steps you can go anywhere it's not
impressive you're not gonna be on the
cover of Fast Company magazine but who
gives a rip people on the cover of Fast
Company magazine three years later a
broke little bit
baby steps one other time keep pushing
it you got this Chris we got your back
here